Arkansas is now proudly and defiantly
led by new governor Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the daughter of former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee and she is
wasting no time my friends she has gone
right to the heart of the matter of what
is most creating a problem for the state
of Arkansas she is Banning critical race
theory in K-12 schools which is not
taught in Arkansas
in K-12 schools huh wait a second I'm
not sure here is Sarah Huckabee Sanders
on Fox News Sunday the day before
yesterday and she is asked about the
anti-critical race Theory meth uh
measure that she signed despite the fact
that it's not taught in schools and she
had an answer ready here is that answer
that's right and we talked during the
commercial about the fact that you're
now growing up in the house or your kids
will grow up in the house where you grew
up
this time around but it sounds like your
daughter is going to grow up in this
face you did as well
um you hit the ground running this week
after inauguration a number of executive
orders
um some folks love them some folks do
not let's talk about your critics uh
reaction to some of these orders one of
them is called executive order to
prohibit indoctrination and critical
race theory in schools the House
minority leader there in Arkansas a
Democrat says this we can't support our
teachers if we alienate and insult them
with headline grabbing executive orders
she says CRT is not being taught in
Arkansas schools axio seems to back her
up they said reality check there's no
indication that the college level course
is taught in any Arkansas Public School
so that's true why the executive order
right
small government it's incredibly
important that we do things to protect
the students in our state we have to
make sure that we are not indoctrinating
our kids and that these policies and
these ideas never see the light of day
now of course a smart question here
would be do you have evidence that they
are being indoctrinated by critical race
theory that question is not asked we
should never teach our kids
assistant evil country in fact it should
be the exact opposite we know for a fact
that the Federal Department of Education
issued CRT guidance and policies to
every school district in the country our
job is to protect the students and we're
going to take steps every single day to
make sure we do exactly that and that's
the reason I signed the executive order
I'm proud of the fact that we're taking
those steps and we're going to continue
to do it every single day that I'm in
office can teachers though still have
the uncomfortable conversations about
the sins of our past about the things
this country has gotten wrong
our teachers absolutely need to teach
our history but they shouldn't teach our
kids and our students ideas to hate this
country and of course they are not being
taught that we must protect our students
vulnerable children from things which
are not being taught to them and this is
actually a classic of the American right
wing it's a classic of reactionary
populism it's a classic of
authoritarianism you invent a problem
and then you solve it you put out the
fire that you started but in this case
it's a fake fire in in in reality it
could be taught though David it could be
taught oh but it is not now there's
there's sort of two uh big aspects to
this one is they claim to be small
government conservatives they are now
passing laws against things that could
happen at some point but aren't
happening right now principle we are for
limited government reality we are
passing laws against things that aren't
even taking place not actually limited
government this is why Sarah Huckabee
Sanders ran for government uh for for
governor
um to appear on Fox News to spout
right-wing talking points and to claim
to have solved problems that are only
problems in the minds of these very
right-wingers because Banning something
that is not being taught in school is a
classic example of grandstanding and it
is what Fox News is there for for these
Republicans we're going to deal with the
m M's that are the wrong gender and
we're going to deal with CRT which isn't
being taught and you're going to call us
Heroes for doing it but I want to
mention something else
this is a huge disservice to Arkansas
schools and what do I mean by that look
at Arkansas's rankings when it comes to
education they are in the toilet I don't
know how many times they've been flushed
but they're in the toilet Arkansas is
44th in the country in high school
graduation rate Arkansas is 40th in the
country in overall educational quality
according to U.S news and World Report
and according to Niche it's 49th in the
country in terms of overall educational
quality Arkansas is 44th in the country
in terms of overall educational
performance Arkansas is 45th in the
country in terms of overall child
well-being which includes other factors
like poverty and and food at school and
all these different things Arkansas is
47th in the country in terms of fourth
grade reading proficiency is Banning CRT
which isn't being taught going to help
fourth graders know how to read Arkansas
48 8th and 8th grade math proficiency
and according to the U.S Census Bureau
Arkansas is 48th in the country in terms
of median household income which is
highly associated with educational
outcomes is Banning CRT going to raise
household income in Arkansas which will
improve educational outcomes for kids no
they are Banning CRT which isn't taught
there despite being close to dead last
in so many educational indicators this
is a massive disservice to the people of
Arkansas I hope they see it she never
should have been elected and
um I mean listen meanwhile you look at
how Connecticut and California and
Massachusetts and Illinois and other
states are doing in education they're
not Banning critical race Theory math
scores are up reading proficiencies up
budgets are much healthier you know it's
it's the same old story it really is and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is now at the
front at the Forefront of it